have you ever had a filmmaker submit
their film to Holli shorts have it be
rejected and then come back to you and
say you know what you were right it
wasn't up to screening level that kind
of I don't yeah it really hasn't
happened that I can recall and the wreck
story now and that's something I think
is interesting I think it should happen
I think you know there's various ways we
can do things to help encourage people
to come out like if if again if people
follow up they give you reject some
rejection letters people may not follow
up or say anything quite frankly we're
not gonna like chase them down to hey
you should write back to me or give me a
response to my reject you know obviously
I can I chase that down
but many people respond with hey Ida why
did I not get in or some people send
really nice emails or constructive
criticism type of emails like asking for
information or whatever some people
angry sometimes and and of course we're
gonna probably ignore that if it's
really nasty in that kind of stuff you
get all types of responses but we'd like
to see is more people respond with hey I
like to have a more thorough discussion
why why don't I get in or whatever and
we'll say hey here's a diss kind of past
the screenings come to the festival come
check out the film yourself and see what
you see and we can compare and things
like that compare contrast to work you
know and come up to us and talk to us of
what you think or maybe you'll see hey
maybe my film didn't live up to these
standards you know I understand why but
that doesn't happened it's very rare
that that filmmakers will accept the
pass or after that kind of email
actually come take the pass and come
attend the festival and things it does
happen sometimes not very often but as
far as the next step of like coming up
watching the films actually having a
conversation with us I've never had that
conversation to anyone like just come up
hey you know Danny I want to talk to you
real quick I saw the films I came you
guys offered this pass to come check out
some films I didn't make it any but I'm
here to see you know and and yeah you
know what I understand or I see these
films and III you know I learned
something about this and that or
whatever the case or just I don't feel
like my film was up to the par that kind
of thing that just never happened and I
think that should happen more often
maybe they can come and say you know
what I don't get it I still think my
feels better fine well we have that
conversation and at least they'd be at
the festival attending watching other
films taking part the exception the
rejection doesn't mean you can't attend
the festival and take part you can still
anyone can buy a ticket regardless of in
or not or you're in the festival five
years ago you come back you can come by
take it it's general public general
festival audience to come see films and
come see the festival and participate
and that should have more often I mean
they talk about at some of the film
schools we talk about films they don't
get in first films do get in and some of
the students of course being
disappointed by classmates or whatever
getting in they don't get in why don't
they come out how come they don't come
out and see the films as well and also
encouraged that you should be at the
festival taking the films and see what
may may have not to work through your
film or why you know understand what's
out there right like if I'm in those
shooting and that's that position I want
to know what's out there I want to know
why what am i up against what was the
reason I didn't get it like that's
that's important information is
something that should be chased down it
should be they should be knocking on our
door to come to attend the screenings
and come to the festival not oh well you
know screw you guys you suck you know
this idea that you know we stalking it's
no one your fault not mine or something
and that's the right mentality about it
and that's that's what I think is sort
of prevailing mentality is that it's
never anyone else's fault but the others
are ours and not to say again we you
know we can get things wrong I'm not
sitting here trying to tower horn or
something you know but it's true that
there is probably a many times a reason
why maybe the film didn't get in and
there's it'd be good and it might
behoove a filmmaker to say you know what
let me go check these films out let me
see what's going on here with this
festival let me see what they're looking
for them you see let me get a little
more information or even research all
the festivals to know what you're
submitting to and things like that like
it's just part of the process you should
know it shouldn't be something to just
act lining to like oh well my film is
amazing my friend my work is the best
and I just believe in a wholeheartedly
so I don't care about anything else I'm
just submitting and I should get in and
and that's it because I'm great like
okay well that's not that's not
necessarily real life here so like you
know like it'd be good if people would
take more initiative that way and I'd be
really happy pleasantly surprised about
having more it just doesn't it's just
you know even offering the things like a
pass discounts and stuff where people
can encourage you can encourage them to
come out and check it out and see what's
what and see you know what other films
are there and maybe they can see what
did or didn't work or why didn't get in
you know like it's not something that's
that happens and it's just interesting
because should have more often it
doesn't just this is rare is where do
you accept rough cuts for submission you
do okay do you recommend that I mean I
don't necessarily recommend it no no I
don't but it's also doesn't we had like
I can think of a
you left up have one right now like this
one film that should have made it that
was a rough cut when they submitted and
it was a giant rough cut too because
there was a whole element missing of a
big part of the story with the visual
effects that would have enhanced they
could made a much better when it was
done but knowing what was there and what
was to come
I can see how great the story could be
in the potential the film was and I was
really enjoying it so I knew that you
know of course I needed to see the final
cut to see what that was cuz the video
if the visual effects were hideous then
that kills the whole thing but they were
great it was really good it was fine but
it's I knew that wasn't like I had a
feeling that was going to be very good
and I loved the movie so it still worked
and ended up getting in so I was a rough
cut and it was a big one in the sense
that a big element of the story was
simply not even there at that time oh
you know it's hard to describe without
getting into details of the story and
stuff but but yeah so yes so some rough
cuts and still make it in no problem so
it's not it's not some kind of detriment
but it can be if it's how many how rough
are we talking here like some films are
they're pretty rough cuts is like okay I
can't even get out good this really is
and just as it stands this cannot
compete so I guess what I'm getting at
is if it's if it's too much of a rough
cut where there's still too many
elements missing it probably is best not
to submit that just for a deadline
especially because look I mean we have
our deadlines but okay earlybird okay
you might save ten fifteen dollars or
something if you submit later vice-versa
if you submit early you save some money
later you if the pay a little pay a
little more but I'd rather pay more
money and have a final cut if I can and
have a chance to get accepted in that
way and my best work forward instead of
saying well I saved a few bucks I'm
gonna submit that deadline I'm so eager
to get the deadline in so if I give any
advice like look don't worry about that
spend the extra money we're talking not
talking to hundra dollars here we're
talking fifteen bucks ten bucks
difference of a deadline wait get it
ready and submit that instead of rushing
for that deadline just to submit it's
better to submit the final cut if you
can
you